give me some of your um background man
like obviously you're from carson yeah
um i had heard of you before you were
working with tde
um you were you know i would say like
you know like if you were
tapped in with two dope boys and some of
the blogs like you were familiar with
what you were doing and then
tde became a part of the situation and
that just kind of made [ __ ] like
super big but how long have you been
making music man like when did you first
start taking this rap [ __ ] serious
um i actually blessed blessed enough i
actually only been making music for six
years so i started in 2014.
wow yeah yeah and um i've been heavy
into music just because i
i liked it like i just liked lyricists
and and rappers that you know i mean
really rapped about stuff and whatnot so
i was super heavy into that
and then um um i played ball and i was
supposed to go to greece to play
basketball
out there and then um one day i just i
just kind of fell out of love with it on
a
business level because i was like you
know i love basketball but i don't
really want to do a business thing with
it
and so i just called my agent and i was
just like no i'm probably not going to
go and then um where you was at
that was like beginning of 2014.
so that was like the beginning of 2014 i
was still in college um so i called him
um told him that and then there was a
part of me that like and that's kind of
what new beginnings symbolizes and we'll
get into that
but it was a part of me that was kind of
scared to do that because basketball was
my comfort i knew that i can go make
money playing basketball like i knew
that like i committed there's anything
else i can do i can
pay my rent there's anything else i can
do i can go play basketball and make
some money
and i was like do i really want to give
up this comfort you know what i'm saying
in this comfort zone or whatever
to do something else and potentially
fail you know what i mean
and so um i ended up making a decision
um and even after i told him i still was
kind of like 50 50. i called him some
days and like well wait hold on
but then when i graduated and um uh i
wrote a song called letter to god which
is like my second song that i wrote
and um i sent it to my brother and we
listened to it and after that that was
that song kind of got me over to fear i
was like i'm
i i think i'm really good at this [ __ ]
let me just
try it and see the shots yeah exactly so
so
where did you go to where did you play
uh basketball is that a d2 called
northwestern state in iowa there's like
a
a swarm of northwesterns in the midwest
um it's like northwestern oklahoma
northwestern iowa i feel like there's a
million northwest
there's a bunch in northwestern yeah
it's like this little like weird yeah
middle of nowhere it's it was awful so
were you a point guard because you're
here yeah i'm not tall enough to yeah be
anything else 100
yeah i mean it's it's crazy because i
like the basketball
hustle like you said like going to
greece like i got i got some homies who
who live in europe and who hoop and like
you said like it's like
you know if you love basketball and
you're like d
like you're good like there's always
like always a place to make
pay your rent there's always a way to
make money and if you could pay your
rent playing basketball bro it's like
now and that was my thing i'm like
like i'm seeing all my my homies like
you know work jobs and stuff and
they hate their job and i'm like like
even though i might not like where i'm
at over there at least i like my job
like
what i'm saying and i can pay my rent
doing it or whatever the case may be but
i just had two nieces and i was in iowa
for two years and i wanted to come back
home i went through like a little racial
situation out there with my coach
and um it was just like i was just like
you know i don't know if i'm ready to
leave again
you know what i mean and so that was
kind of like part of the uh
the the influence behind it was i don't
know if i'm ready to leave
and then on top of that um i was using
music as as
like therapy like i was writing out
there just to kind of pass the time
because i was out there it was only me
and like six other black people at the
school so i didn't really have nobody
yet
i didn't really have anybody to talk to
relate to so i was just kind of writing
as kind of like a therapeutical thing
and i started liking it
so i was like man let me just you know
record a couple things so i came home on
spring break and recorded
a couple records and that's kind of when
i decided like you know i'm just going
to do this and see how it works out
when you say you had a racial situation
with your coach what happened um
basically i had a coach that uh i mean
he was racist
to to you know keep it fun yeah to keep
it funky we used to have it was me and
three other black players
we used to have black only meetings
before the games um
that you guys conducted or that he would
be like i just want to meet with the
three black guys and talk to them about
how they need to play to fit into like
this
role like and then he would like say the
n word to us like in
metaphorically like so not at us but
he's still saying right right
um one time he used this example where
he was like you know he was like white
people are the brain
black people are the soul mexicans are
the heart because you know they work
hard and uh you know make everything go
he was like when you put all three of
them together it's a beautiful thing but
if you had to pick one
wouldn't you rather be the brain like
that like well to be honest if he wanted
to use that reference i would argue that
asian
asian people are the brain
but everything yeah and i would also
argue that you know the heart's kind of
just as important as
you know white people might be like the
kneecaps or something i don't know
i feel like we're not bringing a lot to
the table at 2020. not in 2020 right now
shit's [ __ ] up man so yeah like i went
through that situation and it's funny
even with that situation
like the naacp was getting involved and
stuff and it was about to be big and
i was younger right and so if i had my
brain that i had now i would have
carried it all the way through and went
because i
i feel like i could have changed some
things over it's an intimidating fight
for kids yeah
yeah i just want to go home bro like if
y'all can make it to where i can go home
after the season and just
like work do my schoolwork from home and
come back to graduate and leave again
then like we got a deal and my mom
didn't want me to do that she wanted me
to stay and fight
um but i just ended up saying like you
know like i just want to come home so
that's what they let me do after the
season was over i went home i worked
from home
did all my school work from home sent it
in they kind of just passed me because
they were just they're like we don't
want to get over here yeah we don't want
no smoke like so
i was kind of just turning in whatever
is this guy still coaching he is
unfortunately there
he is unfortunately yeah what the [ __ ]
yeah and if you've been to that town
it's like it's one of those places that
it's like
bro nothing to never change there
because there's nothing there like
there's nothing there to make it
you know what i'm saying like change and
that's the reason why that is one regret
that i do have
i hate having regrets in life but if i
could go back i would fight that you
know
because he doesn't need to be coaching
like to just to be completely honest hey
put his name out there so people can
you know i honestly legally can't oh
you're not legally can't you well the
it's not hard to find though like people
can look at it google it yeah people can
look and find what college i went to for
sure for sure but yeah
yeah that's unfortunate yeah it's crazy
um
and just really quick uh the crazy thing
about it is that so he has a nephew
that's in the nba right now
that is complete opposite like he does
like
podcasts and stuff about racial
discrimination against black white guys
and
a white guy j.j reddick i told you i
can't i can't say what it is but
like it's crazy the opposites though
like he is like his nephew was like
hard working fighting against like
racial discrimination we'll talk about
it i listen to the j.j reddy's podcast
he has he actually does have a great
podcast i just got hip to it like
recently
yeah that's dope man yeah i'm a huge
basketball guy so yeah i actually don't
listen to
as much man it sucks because i listen to
like
certain [ __ ] like i like gravitate to an
album yeah and then i'm just stuck with
it
like i'm still listening to [ __ ] like
freddie gibbs and alchemist
alfredo which was incredible though for
sure but and then like
outside of that i'm just i'm just
listening to sports talk radio like a
degenerate
sports gambler but um yeah man that's
that's wild i didn't know that about you
bro yeah you know i was it was a crazy
situation you know what i mean and it's
uh
um it's weird cause like when i write
music i never know what i'm gonna touch
on so i feel like
one day it's something that i'm gonna
touch on but i never come into songs
like
purposely right like so i'm just like
one day it'll come spilling out and i'll
talk about it you know what i mean so
yeah yeah no that's wild i think that um
i think that's important too for you to
share that because i'm sure there's
people
who are going through maybe similar
situations maybe not on a basketball
team but yeah
yeah like whether it's their boss or
corporate environments anything
yeah man it's just [ __ ] up right now
like and
people get people got to stand up for
what's right bro yeah yeah
i mean but i will say in 2020 um
because of how chaotic it is like there
always has to be balance and i feel like
like there's more than ever more white
people than ever that's
trying to understand and i always tell
black people in general like
you know don't criticize white people
that are trying to understand that maybe
don't understand it because that's step
one you know what i'm saying is them
trying to
understand it i think that what sucks
about right now is like kind of what you
just said like
if there's no nuance and there's no
room for progress and if it's like
hey yo [ __ ] you off the rip because
you're not exactly where i want you to
be as opposed to like
you're trying you're trying you know
like you know what i'm saying i think
that that's
there's two opposite ends of the
spectrum and i think that's the other
opposite end of the spectrum where it's
like
you know there's people who like you
said like they might not have known
about
i mean and what's crazy it's crazy but
it's like you have to understand that
people's reality or their reality like
some people
genuinely are unaware like yeah stuff
was going on but they didn't know but
they didn't know
they didn't know that it was like and i
tell people all the time like you got to
be understanding bro to people
people's environments like you know what
i mean like there's people out there
that they have nothing against black
people
and but they literally might not have a
black person in their life
there might be people who just don't
grow up like in in that environment
exactly like there's people who grow up
in [ __ ] salt lake city and all they
know is like white mormon kids
you know and if they're trying to be
empathetic i just think that they're
we're losing like a lot of nuance in the
world where it's like
you're either this or you're this yeah
yeah but what if you're like
here or here like you know what i'm
saying you're trying to get here you get
them
yeah i think even politically it's just
[ __ ] up because i i feel like
you can't like i can criticize joe biden
and still say i'm voting for joe biden
it's a fact
you know what i'm saying like i i i
don't [ __ ] with joe biden really
yeah but i'm not voting for donald trump
exactly you know what i'm saying
but i can like there's like nuance like
you got to be able to
like you know ask questions and be
critical
and and just because you're critical
doesn't mean like
you ain't you ain't for whatever the
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying exactly
well the issue is that we're in an
environment right now where it's like
everybody jumps out the window for
everything like it's like you can't be
you can't even have a conversation about
something it's like you gotta pick you
get them saying like you have to pick
what it is
right now and if you don't and you even
play the fence
then it's like you know then they're
just gonna label you like okay well then
you're over here you're saying
so yeah like i was like a big bernie
sanders supporter and um
and i had people like dig up tweets i
said about joe biden like yo man you
[ __ ] you don't even [ __ ] with this
i'm like yeah like
obviously i'm not like crazy about joe
biden like
he's probably the least candidate out on
that side that i would love that
but you know what the other side is is
terrible
[ __ ] hitler you know like the worst
possible [ __ ] in the world
like i would vote for like anybody like
literally anyone else
like that it could be george w bush like
i'm running the
g-dub vote you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] it run iraq backwards joe biden
would have to personally
put out an attack on my family for me
tonight joe biden would have to put out
like an entire like
this album like just dissing every race
ethnicity sexually
come on bro like it's crazy